newly released video is shedding light
on the moments before police shot and
killed a homeless man
in california 42 year old kurt reinhold
was killed last september
in san clemente that's south of l.a
deputies had stopped him for alleged
jaywalking
as jonathan vigliotti reports the
incident is now under investigation and
we should warn you once again
this video is disturbing the video
begins with orange county sheriff's
deputies eyeing kurt reinhold
as he crosses the street
you can hear audio of officers debating
whether reinhold is jaywalking
i have control man i don't know it is
when they approach him on the sidewalk
the confrontation
escalates quickly
[Music]
this cell phone video was shot by a
witness across the street
stop touching it stop touching it
what is your problem the deputies
wrestle reinhold to the ground and the
sheriff's department claims a deputy
can be heard yelling he's got my gun
before one of them
opens fire
while the sheriff's department claims
motel surveillance video
shows reinhold's hand on the weapon it's
not
clear whether he was trying to unholster
it we withhold judgment and do not draw
any conclusions
about whether or not our deputies acted
in a manner consistent with our policies
and in accordance with the law until all
facts are known and the investigations
are complete
reinhold's death sparked protests in the
city the father of two had been
diagnosed with schizoaffective disorder
the deputies were part of the homeless
outreach team which the family lawyer
says
should have been better trained to
handle the situation
this is a blatant
racially motivated stop attorney john
taylor who represents kurt reinhold's
family
says the officers targeted reinhold
before taking his life
they create the confrontation they
escalate the confrontation
they're the first person to put their
hands on him and they end up you know
taking his life for cbs this morning
jonathan vigliotti
los angeles reinhold's family has now
filed a lawsuit we did reach out to the
orange county sheriff's department for
an
interview or additional comment but we
did not hear back a question to me is
why do you stop
the guy for jaywalking or alleged
jaywalking in the first place i saw no
cars in sight
i mean that's that's the issue i mean
why stop him at all
i mean he shouldn't have even been
stopped from the looks of a jaywalking
really
you know a lot of people could say it's
called living your life as a person of
color in this country it's just another
example i'm
so glad that there is videotape yes that
there is videotape to show once again
how this situation
seemed to what from what we saw escalate
in a way that it really didn't need to
it really didn't need to why did it even
start
yeah let's start with that let's start
with that thank you for the videotape
the story
is ongoing and we'll stay on top of it